invitée musicale de cette édition du 29
octobre du 7-8 petit home bonsoir mais
ses auteurs compositeurs interprètes
premier album rêves de gamin voici la
pochette l'album est ici et on verra
également s'afficher à l'écran rêve de
gamin pourquoi parce que c'était un rêve
de gamin justement de sortir un album
ouais il ya un peu tôt mais carrément
rêve de gamin et puis il ya quelques
chansons à l'intérieur qui explique
aussi un peu plus dont celle que je vous
ferai tout à l'heure donc on ça explique
aussi un petit peu le titre de l'album
vous allez jouer effectivement la
guitare vous accompagnons n'a pas eu à
les cacher à côté de la table
vous étiez déjà venu sur ce plateau
aussi pour jouer d'ailleurs un morceau
we en 2000 j cependant une chose en vous
avez fait qui s'est passé quoi
l'actualité petit home pendant deux ans
c'était quoi j'étais venu il ya deux ans
de ça pour le festiv'art nahla depuis il
ya eu quelques autres dates d'autres
petit festival des barres et puis
beaucoup de chansons et du coup ce
premier album qui arrive et qui a
demandé quand même pas mal de boulot
comme moi c'était le premier essai une
autoproduction du coup voilà c'était la
découverte au jour le jour et je pour
chaque étape
donc du coup il ya eu vraiment ce
premier album qui est un peu un rêve de
gamin
et pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas
vous avez débuté la guitare à 15 ans le
temps de l'écriture est venue après avec
comme influences entre severino django
reinhardt georges brassens aussi
influences très variées
ouais c'est qui a bercé veuve un petit
peu votre en voilà ce qui sait ce qui
passait chez moi donc
donc voilà je me suis inspiré de ce que
je connaissais donc chanson française et
jazz manouche pour aider votre estime
menacée ça et ça se traduit comment on
va l'écouter tout de suite un petit
morceau je vous laisse a juste le temps
de prendre votre guitare et je rappelle
la sortie de cet album de tito mon rêve
de gamin autoproduit et vous allez nous
en parler un peu plus justement que ce
statut d'auto production pour cet album
auparavant on vous écoute
fallait voir est tant qu'amant avec mon
chapeau de robin un bout de bois en
guise de gourdins
un aspect dans la poche arrière pour
faire fuir mes adversaires imaginaires
patins console ni mes ordis juste mais
kroll et c'est parti mon arrêt fais dans
un étui
la partie sauvé marianne voit le monde
s'il va mal
et dire que je voulais être un de
héros
le genre qui sauva planète avec une cape
aux achats
bref allez voir est un gamin dépôt c'est
mon chapeau drogba mon non stériles
paiement gourdin la journée doucement ce
terminée mais le combat continue et des
parcs avec l'obscurité des démons plus
abstrait alors mme dressant sion lee
prend dix ans l'oreiller j'te les la
guerre est déclarée frappé tous les
côtés mais s'il s'avérait être forte
moi j'ai appelé les renforts avec papa à
mes côtés on leur mettait la battait
et dire que je voulais être c'est
de héros
le genre qui sauve la planète avec une
cape ou un chapeau
où
mais flacon à l'instant disparaît le
héros m'attendent sont sortis ta bouche
c'est quelques mois je me sens tout
flagada chant plume coeur qui bat je
vais faire un malaise est tombé
dans le coma car non pour moi tu viens
de me dire c'est du monde tig à khanty
bouge-toi grandit en moi depuis quelques
mois je suis pas très fort métaphore
mais si je remet les choses à plat
quelques mois et me v'là papa
on
et dire que je voulais être là
c'est de héros
le genre qui sauve la planète avec une
cape au chapeau je me sens complètement
désarmé au bouclier vient de céder mon
lance pierres ont une épée en bois ne
mettront pas cette fois comme je sais
pas ce que tu attends moi je te prends
dans mes bras je te sens complètement
apeuré alors pour nous rassurer je te
dis qu'on en a connu d'autres
ça a toujours été même si c'est toi
c'est différent et qu'il faut bien
avouer que nous nommé responsable d'un
petit bout si fragile c'est limite un
peu inconscient de la part des parents
on
merci à tito mais bravo pour cette
interprétation live sur ce plateau
extrait de cet album rêves de gamin
titre qui s'appelle un de héros a
plutôt d'euros voilà l'a fait la teneur
de l'album et est autour de ça justement
vous parler de vous du quotidien c'est
un petit salé chanson petit celle là
était celle-là avec la première qui
s'appelle les quenottes soit un petit
peu ralliée avec le titre de l'album
parle de moi de mon enfance et de la
transition entre l'enfance et l'âge
adulte
ensuite les autres chansons ça peut
parler d'un petit peu de tout de la vie
de tous les jours de ce qui se passe de
en fonction de l'inspiration de ce qui
vient un petit peu de tout elton c'est
toujours avec un chapeau ouais toujours
avec un châssis obligatoires voilà une
histoire pour le chapeau bas c'est plus
facile dans les bars quand on fait
tourner chapeau c'est une bonne
explication et vous serez sur scène je
donne tout de suite les dates vendredi 2
novembre ce sera au blizzard dans le
xième à paris à 21h également le 18
janvier à 20 heures c'est un petit peu
plus tard au cube et l'est toujours à
paris dans le 10ème les sites internet
se sont affichés vous pourrez y
retrouver toutes les dates à venir de
tito l'album autoproduit on disait tout
à l'heure
pourquoi autoproduit bas tout simplement
parce que j'ai pas trouvé de producteur
déjà d'une part c'est pas un choix dès
le début c'était un choix dangereux
je crois que les producteurs déjà ne
prennent plus trop de risques donc du
coup sa fille de faire un cd on m'a dit
aussi aujourd'hui oui pourquoi faire un
cd alors que le marché du cd un petit
peu aussi en vrac donc voila moi c'était
quand même un projet que qui me tenait à
coeur donc j'y suis allé même si j'ai dû
trouver mes propres financements et puis
et puis me débrouiller un petit peu par
moi-même ben voilà il est sorti
aujourd'hui je suis content d'avoir fait
ça de a à z
et voilà je trouve que le résultat est
vraiment chouette et aujourd'hui vous
faites le service après vente de cet
album est passé beaucoup de temps sur
scène maintenant il va falloir vendre ce
cd vous l'avez retourner sur scène aussi
rapidement
voilà bah moi je le vends après ce cd je
le vends après mes concerts donc c'est
vrai que là j'essaye de faire le maximum
de concerts voilà effectivement vous
procurer rêve de gamin il suffit d'aller
voir tito mon concert ou de se rendre
sur son site internet ça a été difficile
justement de mettre entre parenthèses
peut-être un petit peu la scène que vous
avez beaucoup fréquenté pour entrer en
studio faire un album c'est un exercice
différent
oui c'est complètement différent et puis
ce qui est marrant c'est que en fait le
temps quand on est en studio c'est la
scène qui nous manque
donc ça c'est un petit peu un petit peu
pénible d'être tout le temps enfermé
entre quatre murs et puis de voilà de
leur écoute erreurs et écouter et
réécouter les chansons c'est un petit
peu compliqué quoi heureusement j'ai été
bien entouré avec avec des personnes à
la fois les gens du studio il ya deux
personnes qui sont venues aussi pour
faire des petits arrangements en plus
sur l'album et la scène vous manque
d'autant que vous avez eu des prix 1 sur
le sur scène en victoire sur plusieurs
tremplins à paris dans les yvelines
aussi ça c'est en plus quand on est
artiste de se dire ça y est je vais dans
le bon chemin je vous reconnais je
reçois des prix voilà c'est agréable et
puis certains prix dont
le dernier qui m'a aidé en fait qui a pu
me permettre de faire ces
enregistrements à des coups quand même
minime donc ça c'était ça vous fait pas
peur vous lancer sur le marché du disque
non j'y réfléchis pas trop on vous
posait pas la question
non je me dis que bah si ça se vendra ça
se vendra et puis sinon si ça doit se
télécharger ça se téléchargera et puis
voilà on sait que là c'est que la
musique tourne et que voilà et puis même
si c'est elle est chargée juste écouter
sur le site ou que l'album ait acheté
l'important c'est que les gens
connaissent les chansons qui viennent à
mes concerts qui chante avec moi et qui
est un partage et pourquoi pas un
producteur pour le prochain album vous
avez là j'ai envie même si là on a
compris le studio vous avez très envie
d'y être d'être réservé le préférait
retourner sur scène mais si un
producteur qui se manifestaient pour la
suite ah bah oui oui tout à fait je
serais preneur
ça ce serait vraiment vraiment chouette
oui il ya d'autres textes ils sont pas
encore sorties non des choses qui
pourraient sortir son prochain cd ya des
textes qui sont ou étaient prêts à
laisser en route
tito rêve de gamin voilà un premier
album autoproduit qui était donc notre
invité ce soir et morceaux en live merci
aux nouveaux venus avec votre guitare
sur ce plateau une toute dernière
information pour terminer cette édition
du 7 8
les chiffres du chômage pour septembre
officialisé sans surprise la situation
se dégrade aussi dans le département des
yvelines +2 9% d'augmentation elle ce
qui porte à plus de 10% de la population
active le nombre de chômeurs de
demandeurs d'emploi cinquante trois
mille neuf cents personnes
à noter tout de même que la ville
d'houdan dans le département fait figure
de contre-exemple seulement 4,7 pour
cent de chômeurs des chiffres fournis
par l'insee c'est la fin de cette
édition n'oubliez pas que vous pourrez
la retrouver dès demain mardi matin sur
notre site internet vous pourrez
également nous retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux pour laisser tous vos
commentaires et vos appréciations sur
nos programmes nouvelle édition demain
en direct à partir de 18h le 7-8 se
poursuit même pendant les vacances
excellente soirée